hey everyone richie here we were able to
get our hands on sonic colors ultimate
and try out the first few acts of
tropical resort
via parsec act 3's gameplay was kindly
provided to us by sega themselves
if you like sonic and are hyped to see
colors return drop a like and subscribe
for even more sonic videos coming soon
enjoy
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
valuables huh your vehicles
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with the owner of a white [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
please report to the security
[Applause]
[Music]
the following rides are closed for
[Music]
repairs
[Music]
he loves to hear his own lips flap but i
gotta hand it to the eggster
this place is epic everyone and their
brother is gonna want to come here
no doubt but now i'm not sure why we're
here
this place looks totally harmless
because eggman
plus secretly built amusement park
equals evil plot for us to foil
lucky for us he's not very good at
keeping things hidden
true it would be pretty hard to miss a
giant
floating space amusement park surrounded
by planets
still an evil plot i don't know
wow plot or not you can't be mad at this
view
this place is taking beauty to the next
level i'm just surprised that it was so
easy to sneak in here
uh i wouldn't say it was that easy
hello happy people buckle up as
eggman's ultra accelerating space
elevator
whisks you to an interplanetary
wonderland of fun
[Music]
i can't believe somebody was dumb enough
to leave the keys in this thing
it's like eggman's begging us to sneak
in and trash the place
[Music]
this amusement park has been constructed
entirely out of a sense of remorse for
my past transgressions
and is in no way associated with any
sort of evil plot or premeditated
misdeeds
that's a relief
just thinking about it makes my head
feel like it wants to
[Music]
aliens your voice chip is stuck on
cowboy again
stop talking and make those aliens
i'm not sure what's going on but i'm
sure of what i'm gonna do
[Music]
hey what's going on
huh wow
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
morning
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
matter uh us unless you didn't have fun
[Music]
[Music]
you